you've obviously spent a good amount of
time with him and and i think that
one of the pieces that to me is very
obvious is
uh he one is misunderstood to
um because he is so ambitious
and believes so deeply that he and his
team can drive
so much innovation uh it's an easy
target to attack both in the media
in private etc maybe uh help us
understand a little bit
as you've actually spent time with him
like what are your takeaways and kind of
how do you evaluate uh both him as a
person but also too
kind of those ambitions across spacex
tesla
and then we can get into some of the
hyperloop stuff after that yeah
well my experience has been you know
incredibly
um meaningful uh we've had some
experiences like
traveling together uh to to here square
to uh sorry two did you know he he saw a
trip that i did to
to here square in the middle of the
revolution and then i went to
libya in the middle of the revolution
same trip uh with sean penn and we met
with the rebels in in uh
benghazi as they had liberated like two
weeks before gaddafi was killed and it
was an incredible
incredible experience and he was like
you know look next trip
you take like that i want to go with you
uh
and i was like well we're thinking about
going to cuba and there was an american
who was in prison for eight years there
and um we were like you know maybe we
could help with that
uh and so we're basically doing hostage
negotiations
as elon likes to tell it um and
you know we coordinated coordinated in
terms of what we were
what our goals were and said you know
and also
the idea of like you know bringing
helping to bring internet
to the island and we knew that
bringing connectivity and communication
to a country can really open things up
and um and so that was the trip and it
took six months to get the approvals and
elon's jet was
the second american plane to land in
cuba in 50 years
and so we landed there and we met with
ministers and we met with university
students we
you know uh you know with you know
castro's son like you know with artists
um
and one of the things we said is like
look you know you've got to release
this american there's nothing to talk
about
if you don't and within a year they
they released them and and then obama
opened up
cuba and rolling stones came in for a
free concert a half a million people and
it affected change right
and in that trip and elon said that was
his favorite
trip at the time um we started talking
about on the plane we started talking
about
uh hyperloop and i remember
you know everything kind of
very clearly and i remember saying look
you know
what are you going to do with it you
know what this was an idea
the paper wasn't written um and
uh what he said was look you know he's
got five boys
spacex tesla solar city
you know he's super busy and he didn't
have time to do it he wanted to open
source in any way so
i said you know do you mind if i try to
you know
create a company around it and he was
like no go ahead and my idea was
i didn't want to just do people
transport i wanted to
revolutionize the idea of
logistics cargo
um and commerce and the idea was
imagine if you could order something
right
online and
it begins to be manufactured in real
time
manufactured distributed and delivered
all within 48 to 72 hours
from anywhere in the world imagine that
kind of real-time
pulse to the global economy and um
and he was like that's a really good
idea and i don't see any technical
reason why you couldn't do people adding
cargo
so that was that was a business model
and i started to
to work on it um and one of the things
you you know
to elon is
one he's an absolute genius two
he is incredibly loyal
i mean uh he's a family person he loves
his family
uh he loves his friend you know close
friends
and he's incredibly loyal uh to those
people into his teams that are
building these these incredible
incredible companies with them
um and i saw multiple examples of that
and it was just you know in every
experience
there's a reason why people build
great things with leaders and
visionaries like that
they are inspired they're inspired to do
something
more with their lives and to contribute
something
to the advancement of our world um
and uh you know there's nothing better
than waking up in the morning
and realizing all these years of work
that you're sending to human beings into
space on a private rocket
like come on how cool is that
look if you see the um the kind of hype
video if you will that nasa and
spacex released today i mean you watch
this thing and you're like
again and i tweeted a couple times i
don't know how you bet against these
people
right you know whether it's elon whether
it's the spacex team whether it's nasa
just the fact that they have worked and
the part i actually wrote about this
morning was
this isn't something that they started
working on two years ago right i mean
we're talking
almost 20 years he's been working on
this problem
and it started from a first principle
standpoint i gotta fix this rocket
technology get the cost down
i have to kind of get cargo and then i
can get people and
and this is a multi-decade type body of
work
that we're just now starting to see um i
think where people say
wait they actually may pull this off
right but it's 20 years in the making
yeah i mean i i all everyone is
praying uh for the safe
journey of the astronauts uh that's
incredibly important
obviously to their to to their families
and
and to the movement of uh humanity
expanding beyond you know our planet um
and you know i i was telling that story
of
having a conversation with elon in 2012
about
humans going astronauts going on in his
rockets
and we were going to the opening
ceremony of the of the olympics in 2012
and we got stuck in traffic we were
going to be late and we saw some bikes
per rim so we jumped out of the car
and uh rented the bikes and biked and
made it
but then my uh my leg cramped as we were
walking
running um and he like put his arms
around
you know supported me to walk to a bench
and then ran and got water
because i was dehydrated obviously and
we sat down we talked and i asked him
about
you know when do you think humans will
go on your rocket
and he was so thoughtful his number one
concern was the safety of the astronauts
um that's all he was concerned about he
was
projecting like 2023 i think and he beat
that
but um but that was his paramount
concern
nothing else he wasn't trying to rush to
get there
and risk you know anyone's life um
and there's always some risk no matter
what you do but it's
also an important reminder that look
we put humans on the moon
in the 60s right i mean
wow i mean you know and and kennedy got
up there and said
you know wanting to put a man on the
moon uh within the decade
and they did it and they did it with
computers with the power of a calculator
today
and it's an incredible achievement but
we should also understand that it wasn't
just
um just an engineering achievement it
was a financial
achievement and decision uh i think the
numbers i saw once
i wrote about this once about the
the actual in kind of 1960s dollars that
they
committed to uh fund
putting a man on the moon within the
decade was something like 250 billion
dollars
right and it was something like four or
five percent of the gdp
at the time and
that's an incredible achievement you
know a
commitment and achievement and so
it's like we've already done this
we have these skills a private company
hasn't done it
our government our people did it but
companies have to
have that skill as well and it's another
area where
where i talk about companies becoming
you know almost like sovereigns right i
call them mini sovereigns and you know
tim cook
of apple has the power
you know and apple has the power and
financial power
of a nation-state amazon and bezos same
thing
google right um and
imagine in the spacex example
if elon pulls it off and he colonizes
mars in the next
20 30 years and begins to seed humanity
there
which is absolutely his goal again it
sounds crazy but that is his goal and
every crazy idea he's had guess what
he did it from paypal
to you know uh to spacex to tesla to
solarcity and so on so like you said
i wouldn't bet against that